Vì bán nhân dân thành phóa nội với bà hành thông báo số ba chính sấu về việc ra soát,
sự lý rất diễm các dự án vốn ngoại ngân xách có sự dụng đất chậm trên khai trên đường bà thành phố.
Nơi là động thái thị hiện quyết tâm của thành phố trong thực hiện sì đạo của thường trực thànhui.
Nhanh sích chặt kỳ cương, nâng cao hiệu quả quán lý, sự dụng một lực đất đại của thành phố.
Theo lỗi dụng thông báo, vì bán nhân dân thành phóa nội yêu cơ các nhà đầu tư,
khẩn trưng báo cáo bằng bàn việc thực hiện dụng an trước ngày bà mi tháng tư.
yêu cầu này ám dụng với bà trong bốn mốt dụng an đầu tư bằng vốn ngoại ngân xách trên đường bà thành phố.
Y bán nhân dân thành phóa nội yêu cơ các chủ đối tư cũng cấp thu tình thực tế về tiến độ đầu tư,
sây dật, dải phóng bằng bằng.
Thư hiện giữa vụ tại chính các dây nghiệp cũng cần nếu những khó khăn,
cho nó phân định gió án viên nhân khách quán chủ quán.
Chúng tôi cũng được đen vì phải đánh giá năng lực thực hiện dự án về tải chính,
vì đồng vốn tổ chức thực hiện.
Lâm gió chính giãi chậm xin khai và để xuất từ án xử li,
càm kết kết kết độ thực hiện.
Nếu sau ngày bà mi tháng tư các chủ đối tư không từ báo cáo,
phóng máo cáo không đặc ứng yêu cầu, không gió năng lực và càm kết thực hiện.
Y bán nhân dân thành phố sẽ ủng bệnh pháp thu rồi, dương thực hiện dãn.